Hi.
So we're, we're going to, uh, we are recording this one.
Uh, did anybody figure out what next week is?
Bowl? Bowl, Super Bowl Sunday, right?
Tim won't be here. Accurate
Statement. So be,
be careful to not ask somebody here.
But, um, so that dawned on me this week,
and I, I communicated a little bit with Jimmy Quinn,
and we don't, the problem is we we're gonna be getting into,
um, spring break if we extend it.
So here's what we're gonna, I'm gonna propose,
see if we got kind of a consensus on this.
Um, see, it wouldn't be smart for you men to have
to tell your wife, I picked Super Bowl
over the marriage in Richmond.
Course. That's a bad place to put it. What
If your wife tells you she picks us?
Tim, I, I think,
I think we've got something in common here.
I didn't mind, but,
Okay. So
are we having a watch party at your house?
Well, we still wouldn't cover the material that way.
So there are people I've been told
who could care less about a Super Bowl, so we're gonna, but,
but finding two together, Savannah, that might be hard.
So please hear this.
Please hear this in the best sense of the framework.
We're gonna record it.
And I actually don't know how to, uh,
distribute the recording,
but I know there are people who do.
And, uh, so I'm gonna record it, uh,
just like I'm doing tonight.
And so if you choose to not be here,
I just encourage you,
just pick a time when you can watch the recording
together, okay?
Mm-Hmm. How's that sound? Very good. Is that good enough?
And, uh, so our, our community groups having one
of those Super Bowl parties,
but we figured out we can get there for dessert.
That's all I care about. Alright.
Anybody, uh, want to just say that book was hard
or good or meaningful?
Anybody get anything out of their weak digging into it?
Mm-Hmm. Okay.
Joyce and I have been involved with that ministry
for 30 years now, either on staff
for about 10 of those years.
Um, closely connected
and doing, doing some projects for them,
uh, the other years.
And we believe that's the best presentation
of the material so far.
And there's a lot more available should you want it.
There's a, these principles are
all about loving God and loving others.
And there's, they have books on children and,
and parenting and all kinds of things.
So that's, you can access it there. Okay.
So tonight we're gonna be talking more about
how we grow as a couple
by experiencing biblical principles so
that we take head knowledge and live it out.
So, um, that's kind of the focus for tonight.
And we're gonna talk about one of the major, um,
can't think of the word sidetracking, things that,
or things that hinders us from connecting.
And when we first heard this particular hindrance talked
about and taught, uh, it was one of those things
that I would have to say I had never
thought about that before.
Certainly from a biblical perspective.
And that's gonna be the topic of aloneness.
So if you, if you were at the workshop, as many of you were
that we did on a Friday night
and Saturday morning, this will be a bit redundant,
but I suspect it'll come out a little differently
than I did it the first time.
And, uh, second thing is, we have never grown tired.
If you're in Dr. Ferguson teach the same stuff,
it's almost like, well, he must be teaching the Bible
because it's got more for you
even when you read it over 10 times, right?
It's kind of like, it's new every morning, right?
So, uh, one of the key things we're gonna talk about
is learning to see people the way God sees 'em in order
to love them the way he loves them, to see people,
the way he sees them in order
to love them the way he loves them.
What that implies is perhaps sometimes we don't see people
as they truly are,
or we misinterpret what's going on
or what they mean, or what they're thinking
and maybe what they're feeling.
Um, you probably heard this old, um, story of
someone who gets on the subway in New York City
and sees this man, middle-aged man
sitting down and he's got three
or four kids of his running around him
and they're out of control.
They're like making all kinds of noise.
They're bumping into people,
they're kind of being a nuisance.
And finally, this man that got on the subway
and witnessed that says to the men,
why don't you take control of your kids?
You're just letting them run rampant.
And then he says, um,
then, then the man who was sitting down, who is the father
of the kid said, I'm sure you don't, in didn't, didn't think
of this, but we just came from the hospital
where their mother died.
You see, that's a way we're not seeing people
the way God sees 'em.
Mm-Hmm. We don't begin
to understand what's going on in people's hearts.
Half of the time. Now,
You Should be, if you've been married in length
of time at all, hopefully you do know how to kind of predict
what your spouse is thinking because you've been with them
and you've been around them, and you can
kind of start to predict.
But it's dangerous to make judgements without
lovingly checking them out.
So if I walk in the door when I get home from the office
and I see Joyce
and she immediately frowns it in my direction,
my default interpretation
of her frown is, she's mad at me again.
What have I done now? But that's an assumption.
Even if it's happened a hundred times
before, it's still an assumption.
Mm-Hmm. Does that make sense? Yeah. Mm-Hmm.
So one thing we wanna do is always slow down the process
and say, Hmm,
I think you're frowning.
What's going on? Help me understand, is it me?
And there's more tools to learn to what if it is okay,
but it could be just got, just got bad news
from somebody and the look was still on my face.
Okay? So that's key point,
seeing people the way God sees them,
so we can love them the way he loves 'em.
Okay, we're gonna watch a video tonight
that introduces you to the authors,
the primary authors of Call to Love, uh, David
and Theresa Ferguson.
And, uh, this video I think is not more
than three minutes long.
And, uh, what they are going to introduce you to
is, uh, kind of how their journey started.
And, um, I think it would be true
to say they're probably in the top 10% of degree
of difficulty of starting a marriage.
Okay. You'll see why. So stay handy.
Cameron,
Did you want the recording to see the
Screen? Ooh,
that would be good. Yes. You just gonna hold it?
That's fine. Thank you.
I knew that was a possibility, but knowing how to do it,
That what I said, I knew that was a possibility,
but somebody actually knowing how to do it.
Oh yeah, yeah. That's very much appreciated.
I just ran it backwards. That's easy to fix.
So I think I can do that.
Good to go? Yep.
Patrica and I share some
of our own journey into marriage intimacy.
I think we're gonna provide some hope to most. Any couple.
You see, we got married in rebellion. We were 16 years old.
Um, now we don't recommend that, but we did that
and endured, uh, quite a bit of pain for a lot of years.
Uh, we came to faith
and following Jesus in our early twenties
and, uh, begin to try to make up
for lost time, try to heal some things.
And yet I remember probably 10, 12 years into marriage,
I asked her one night, uh, Theresa, do you really love me?
It was hard for me to answer that question
because we had had so much pain in our marriage those early
years that, um, it was painful for me to have to say
that I didn't feel anything from David
because those early years we had hurt each other so deeply
and never knew really how to resolve all those hurt.
And she'll be sharing with you a little bit.
For example, even our honeymoon hurt a little bit
later in this series.
Uh, and yet as we began to find some principles
to really bring health
and healing in our marriage,
I can remember one very hopeful time when we were about
to head off to one of our favorite, uh, trips in, uh,
the Smoky Mountains, meet some other couples up there,
enjoy a few days away.
And we were kind of going through the house.
So she was already in the car
and I was being the dutiful husband.
I was locking doors and turning off lights and, uh, checking
The first and only time.
And So I got to the kitchen.
And I remember having this thought, David,
last year when you were up at this mountain retreat center,
they did not have sweet and low for your wife's coffee.
Uh, and I drink my coffee black,
but there needs to be pink stuff in hers.
And yellow goes in oatmeal or something
and blue goes in something.
It's pretty complex loving people these days.
And so anyway, I remember getting
that pink stuff outta the cabinet, put in my briefcase,
didn't tell her that I had it.
Uh, we went on, uh, flew up to Asheville, North Carolina,
got in a rented car, got to the top of the mountain,
had dinner with each friends, bring the dessert,
they bring the coffee, and she's looking around.
There is no sweet lu.
And I love to say the husband's, uh,
you don not think I'm excited or what.
Pull that sweet low outta my pocket.
Come riding in on a white horse to rescue my wife.
And, uh, and she was celebrating.
She had little tears in her eyes
and communicated a sense of feeling loved.
And I remember having two thoughts.
One, how simple it is to love people.
And it was one of those things that I had missed for
so many years of
what we would now call taking thought of her.
And, uh, so it was a real transformative but hopeful moment.
The second thought I remember having was one,
I think from the Lord that kind of said, now David,
didn't we do good?
See David, I needed you to kind
of bring this sweet low up the mountain,
but I promise you, you needed me
to remind you in the kitchen back in Texas.
And there was that sense in which that God
and I had just partnered together, if you will, to love her.
Well. And for me, that was a really exciting,
transformative moment of what marriage, intimacy,
and this journey is all about.
Partnering together with the Lord
to love this one person really well.
Okay, my hope is
another video doesn't start up
while I'm talking about this one.
That's, uh, that's something we tried to kind
of plant the seed of last week.
Did you need, did you need to put that back and record?
I've got it. It's going. Yeah. This, this is, uh, my laptop.
I'm sorry. That's okay. Mm-Hmm. I don't mind that.
Um, this is something we tried to kind of plant the seed of
where the idea that
my first job on planet earth
is to love the Lord with everything I got.
And I'm still a work in progress on that.
But my second job is to love those near me.
Well, and I'm still a work in progress on that too.
But that paradigm is freeing.
It's not about me, my job,
it's about serving her as I'm following the Lord, partnering
with Jesus, getting in the yoke with Jesus
to love her well.
And if she's doing the same basic thing,
we're probably going to make it right.
'cause he'll pick us up and dust us off
and give us a do over if we mess up.
'cause that's what grace is all about.
So just wanted to kind of plant that.
Now I wanna move into this, uh, um, issue
of aloneness.
See, you can be married and often feel alone.
We were 18 years until you married. That's right.
In fact, that was our wake up call was we go
to a seminar thinking we're gonna get something
else out of it.
And the next thing we know we're looking at,
at each other very differently.
We're seeing each other differently.
We're we're looking, not so much
stuck on looking at the behavior of the other person,
but looking at the heart of the other person.
And that was a big shift for us,
as it is for a lot of people.
So I wanna read a quote
that's actually in the guide for this course.
It says this, we can share the same address,
the same dinner table, and even the same bed,
and still feel disconnected from one another.
We can live together for decades
and yet still feel distant and isolated in marriage.
We've all had times in our relationships when we felt like
our spouse didn't really know us
or wasn't able to care for us in ways that were meaningful.
See Joyce, and I like to say that we don't have
to go back more than about 48 hours to have another
testimony from the trenches of how we messed up just
with being short, being impatient.
Folks, I'd like to tell you that when you get
to our age, that doesn't happen.
It does. It sure does.
And, uh, it's kind of a constant, okay, Lord,
take a deep breath, show me your grace.
Help me pass it on.
But that is actually
what good marriages look like.
They do stumble, they do have problems.
They do have disconnects.
They do say things like,
pastor John in our church here was speaking about today.
We, we do have to go back and ask for forgiveness
and, uh, make things right.
So success is not no conflict.
Successes, having the tools and the grace
and the humility to resolve conflict and to repair things.
So there's a biblical account of this.
And I may have shared part of this in that workshop,
but not everybody was there.
I want you to think about the first human created.
His name was Adam.
And he's sitting in the Garden
of Eden having been created by God.
And, uh, he's even got a, uh,
perfectly controlled temper, uh, environment.
How do I know that? 'cause he's naked. Okay, read the text.
I didn't make that up. Um, perfectly controlled environment.
He's got everything he needs.
He possesses everything he needs,
and he's in an exalted position relative
to the animals that are already there.
He gets to name 'em among other things.
But in the midst of being in that perfect garden of Eden
with the perfect relationship with his creator,
there's no sin in the world here.
That's when God shows up
and says, Adam, dude, Houston, we got a problem.
Something's not good. And there's no sin in the world.
It's not good because God hasn't quite finished
his creative work.
And he wired Adam to need not only him God,
but also other humans.
He wired him that way. If you have a problem with
that, take it up with God.
That was his sovereign will to do it that way.
Instead of popping people into existence
as independent little robots that just run around
and do things, he created Adam
with a God shaped vacuum.
The that was already connected,
but he also created him with the need to connect on a deep,
meaningful level with other humans.
And the first provision that God makes for Adam is Eve,
who is like him being a human being, needing
to breathe air and sleep
and do all those things that human beings need.
But he also created Eve in a different gender.
That was part of his plan, okay?
And that's where we point
and say, that's where marriage began.
That was the institution of marriage being set up
by God when he creates Eve.
So Adam had a perfect relationship with God,
but he didn't have a relationship with another human.
Eve gets created, she comes into the world
with a perfect relationship with God
and a connection to Adam,
other provisions of God that can remove aloneness,
that can provide connection, include our families.
I've got a brother that lives here in town,
very close to my brother.
That's another connection that he and I can sit
and talk about things,
whether they're superficial things like football
or there are deep things about, you know, uh,
we were talking the other day about, uh, my mom
and she's long gone,
but we were having a really neat conversation about her.
So family's another provision.
Third provision would be the church.
You see, the church that is the body of believers,
regardless of what building they might meet in
or what they call themselves, if they believe in Christ,
that body of believers is actually equipped
to remove aloneness for one another.
Though many of us for many years, we're not
Aware of how to do that.
We had not been fully equipped,
we had been given the capacity for it.
And that's what our testimony included last week was 19
years before we knew how
to connect on a heart to heart level.
So alone, this is removed
or can be removed through any of those, uh, provisions,
um, I wanna show you, uh, that's the biblical support
for the need for connection, the need for relationship
that goes beneath the surface
with at least some of the people in your life.
There's also scientific evidence that this is true.
And I wanna show you a video of that.
I did not show this one in the, um,
come on, I gotta get out.
Before I was in, I didn't show this video
in the workshop I did,
although many of you have already seen it, I'm sure.
But in three minutes it kind of shows
what would take 30 minutes to an hour to really explain.
This is called the still Face Experiment.
Um, I saw this first about nine or 10 years ago, uh,
because I was at a training conference for a counseling
model that was developed by non-believers.
But it's sound, it's a good model.
It's just the person that developed it was,
um, not a believer.
Um, later on she actually co-wrote a book
with the believer to say,
here's the Christian version of this model.
So she's at least not close-minded to us Christians.
But, um, they showed this as a way to help us see
what can we learn from a, an infant
who isn't even old enough to speak yet.
What can we learn about human nature from an infant?
So let's see if this plays. Well,
Babies this young are extremely responsive
to the emotions and the reactivity
and the social interaction
that they get from the world around them.
This is something that we started studying
oh 34 years ago when people didn't think
that infants could engage in social interaction.
And the still face experiment.
What the mother did was she sits down
and she's playing with her baby, who's about a year of age
Like girl.
Oh. And she gives a greeting to the baby.
The baby gives a greeting back to her.
This baby starts pointing at different places in the world
and the mother's trying to engage her and play with her.
They're working to coordinate her emotions
and their intentions, what they want
to do in the world. And that's,
Uh, what you've just witnessed there.
It's so common, isn't it?
Even if you see a baby
that's not yours may not even be related to you,
but you see 'em in a restaurant
or something, they make eyes at you.
And the next thing you do, you gotta smile here
or here, right?
There's actually part of your brain that's designed to cause
that to happen called mirror neurons.
It's hard to say the word mirror, but that's what they are.
And they help us connect for people.
Again, fearfully and wonderfully made.
Your brain is we're just now discovering
and understanding more and more about it.
So that, that's just happened.
I would call brain food for an infant.
They can't tell what those words mean,
but when they see that smiling face that seems
to be expressing delight, I promise you
that is helping that child develop relationally as well
as can be done at that age when their needs are met.
But not only the need for food
and to have your diaper changed and that kind of stuff,
but when their connection need is met,
it's reinforcing a sense of security in this child.
Somebody loves me even though she doesn't have that ability
to think in words yet, but it's giving her a secure
and safe place to be with someone.
Okay? That's the way it's supposed to happen.
And it's supposed to continue that way through life.
Now, when you get to be 17, 18, roughly, you know that age,
you ought to be learning how to give that
to other people by then, right?
That's where you develop the ability.
But your ability to give it to others is best
accomplished if you received it growing up consistently
and abundantly, if not perfectly.
Okay? Now let's see what they have her do that's different.
This is really what the baby is used to.
And then we ask the mother to not respond to the baby.
The baby very quickly picks up on this.
And then she uses all of her abilities
to try and get the mother back.
She smiles at the mother, she points
because she's used to the mother looking where she points
the baby puts both hands up in front of her
and says, what's happening
Here?
She makes that screechy sound at the mother.
Like, come on, why aren't we doing this?
Even in this two minutes, when they don't get the normal
reaction, they react negative emotions, they turn away,
they feel the stress of it.
They actually may lose control of their posture
'cause of the stress that they're experiencing.
I'll rescue you, all of you moms who are about
To come. And
Even some of those guys,
there's another piece to this.
But if you saw a baby
squirming crying, maybe even wailing
or screeching in a grocery store,
see, if we don't see people the way God sees 'em,
we might think as, I think my mom told me,
that's a fussy baby.
Don't be like that. And my mom was not a bad woman,
but she was really in, it was real important for her
to have us not be disrupting, what did he call it?
Instead of a character flaw in a baby
or immaturity in a baby for 1-year-old.
And what, what's immaturity to a wonder?
Instead of him labeling it immaturity
or a character flock, what did he call it?
Did you catch it? He said,
this baby is distressed.
You see, that's the natural brain reaction function.
When it, when the brain's doing what it's supposed to do,
it's saying, okay, we have had this safe connection
to this mom for a whole year.
Now she's disappeared.
Now she's right there in front of her. Right?
But you see what I mean? She's disappeared,
she's quick connecting.
Whatever I do seems to be invisible.
And that's why she goes through a sequence
of things that come to her mind.
I think I'll get her attention this way.
Well, that didn't work. I think I'll smile and charm.
No, that didn't work. I want to get away from this.
I look away. That didn't seem to bring mom back.
It might have reduced the tension slightly,
but it didn't bring mom back.
That is natural.
God ordained, pre-wired, wired,
self preservation activity showing up in a 1-year-old.
And guess what folks? We do adult, adult versions of
that sometimes when we don't feel seen or heard
or cared for, join the club.
Okay,
I'm here and whatcha doing? Oh,
She's bad.
It's a little like the good, the bad and the ugly.
The good is that normal stuff that goes on
that we all do with our kids.
The bad is when something bad happens,
but the infant can overcome it.
After all, when you stop the still face, the mother
and the baby start to play again.
The ugly is when you don't give the child any chance
to get back to the good, there's no reparation
and they're stuck in that really
Ugly situation.
Any reactions to that? Thoughts? Reflections?
Come on, y'all. Remove my aloneness up here.
What do you think?
I can see how it reflects that, you know, my relationship
with my wife where I don't respond when she's asking her.
Yeah. Jillian, thank you so much
for being transparent about that.
Um, we, I bet you most of us, me
and if not all of us, could say something similar,
but that's a great application to pull out from that.
See how that might be.
Part of what's needed in my spouse
is more responsiveness.
Okay? And there could be things in
the hearts of those of us who aren't being responsive.
That kind of help would help us understand why we're
not more responsive.
But we don't want to use those reasons as excuses.
We just want to understand what's getting in my way. Okay.
And do it nonjudgmentally. How can I get better?
Somebody else? Thoughts
or reflections? Yeah.
I grew up in an alcoholic home
and I don't think I learned some of the connection skills.
And so even a
conversation my wife and I had tonight was about this area
of our relationship and the ability to connect.
And, um, it's just, uh, recognizing
that it's not there is one thing.
It's another thing to recognize how to,
Um, Have that tool that you mentioned Yeah.
That I've never, ever received. So
That'd be a shame.
Thank you for sharing that. By the way.
It'd be a shame if we were more aware there's a problem,
but didn't have a tool or a way to get better.
It'd be like just expecting that,
that basketball team to go back out there
and get better without showing 'em how.
So we definitely want to have these tools to work from
and we'll, we'll be building those in.
Sorry Jason. So sorry to hear that happen to you
as a boy. Yeah,
I was gonna add that, that,
and then that was reinforced as an adult.
'cause I work in the construction ministry
and I learned about the, well, I started working at the age
of 11 from heavy equipment
and I learned don't bring your feelings to work.
Yeah. And so, which is one thing for work,
but then you go home at the end of the day.
And so it doesn't,
that doesn't work real well. So,
You know, that's a great example by the way.
Uh, in homes where there's alcoholism present
that is one, or both parents are, um,
alcoholic dependent on alcohol drinking frequently
or that whole thing,
rarely can they meet the emotional needs of the children.
That's almost a given.
Well, if the emotional needs of the child aren't met,
that means there isn't that safe haven.
At least not consistently.
And when he said, what if the child gets,
or what if the, there's no recovery for the child,
that's the ugly where they don't get repair.
So just imagine if the, if the family system
either had something like alcoholism
that was getting in the way and causing problems
or just, um, extreme neglect, uh,
or too busy on various levels,
the child's not necessarily getting everything they need.
Okay? And yet most of us in this room
probably didn't get everything we needed
and we're still recovering and growing.
And like me came to know the Lord as an adult,
that helped tremendously.
But there was still a lot of healing and repair to be done.
So those are great examples.
Um, the thing that removes aloneness
that we can begin to use or apply more
and more consistency consistently is
what the Bible calls intimacy.
Now when I mention the word intimacy
or intimate, what's the first word
that comes up in your mind?
Come on, somebody's saying success. Now.
It's one reason why some of us suggested to Dr.
We should probably rename the counseling model.
Instead of calling it intimacy therapy.
We ought to call it something else.
And he said, Nope, I'm sticking with that word.
It's God's word and we are claiming it. Okay?
But I'm gonna pass this around.
There's enough for one per couple. Okay?
This is a definition out of, uh, the Britannica of what they
describe as intimacy.
And I need one copy of that, Chuck. Thank you.
I can't remember what it says before.
Um, here's what the Britannica a secular
publication says.
But you'll have the whole thing to take home
and read later if you want to you.
It says, intimacy is a state of being intimate,
which is marked by consensual sharing.
Notice that consensual, that means not forced,
not demanded consensual sharing of deeply
personal information.
It has cognitive, effective and behavioral components.
That is my body language actually helps communicate.
Am I being transparent
and am I being vulnerable when I share something
really personal about me?
Or am I just raising my voice
as I've been guilty of so many times?
Now it's, it's more of how can we share
what really matters to us?
That's deep intimates.
Or people who are being intimate relationally reveal
themselves to one another.
They care deeply about one another
and they are comfortable in close proximity.
Lemme give you an example of two warriors in the Bible.
Somebody, some of you may already know who I'm thinking of
in the Old Testament.
There's some, many, many chapters about these two guys.
One was King David, who's the other one? Jonathan. Jonathan.
Jonathan. Jonathan was the son of who? Saul King. King Sa.
King Saul. So King Saul was in authority.
And then here comes King David.
And God picks King David, who's gonna be the next rule.
Saul doesn't like that. So he starts trying to,
he see King David's getting popular with the people.
So he starts to chase after him, even intending to kill him.
Jonathan Saul's son goes so far as to warn David
multiple times and save his life or help help him.
But there's an interesting reference to their relationship.
It says they were knit together in the soul.
I think you could use foxhole buddy as an analogy.
These guys fought wars together. They are men's men.
If we want to use that kind of a label,
they probably qualified,
but they have this deep, caring, connected relationship
where I think it's safe to say they had each other's backs.
They would die for each other.
So when it comes to us men being relationally intimate,
sharing our deep thoughts
and feelings, you got some pretty good
examples to follow there.
Does that make sense? It is a myth
that says men don't have feelings.
We just express them differently.
In many ways, men are often referred to
as having passion,
not just in a sexual way, but in other ways.
And I would say, well, so do women.
But that's evidence of there's a motion that can be very
powerful and strong even when it's being used
for nothing but good.
So we can embrace this idea of
being relationally intimate.
Um, God's provision for, I,
I'm sorry, I'm reminded of the part,
something I read in chapter one that said, I mean,
it's not just laying in bed talking about
what groceries you need
to buy when you need to mow the yard.
Yeah. Those aren't intimate conversations.
No. And, and yet they're necessary conversations.
Aren't they made a grocery list before we came here tonight?
Guess where we're going? But that's not intimacy.
If you grew up in an environment where that mother
and that dad stayed connected to you
and made it okay for you to even complain
until we found out what's really going on
with this complaint, I don't like Susie anymore.
Well, it could be Susie's said something to her.
Whatever it is. If you grew up in that kind of environment,
then superficial conversation may be about as good
as you can get because you're just not yet safe
or equipped or a combination of the two.
Those are two fixable problems.
Creating safety and showing you how
to communicate when it's talking about
feelings and stuff like that.
So the antidote
for aloneness is intimacy on a relational level,
which could be applied in a friendship.
Okay? Could be applied to workers.
Somebody mentioned a business where, uh, that was,
I think you, uh, Jason, uh, where
they basically told us stuff it there too, right?
There's a company called McCoy's Building Supply.
So lumberyard company in Texas has about a hundred stores,
uh, primarily in Texas.
The head of that company about 20 years ago,
started having us teach these principles
to his leadership,
stripping out the Bible verses.
'cause he didn't want to impose his faith on them.
But if anybody asked, where'd you get these ideas?
We didn't hesitate to tell 'em, write out
that black book right there.
Okay? And in that, those companies,
leadership is expected to be able to listen
at a deep level to try to help their employees.
So if you look in the Bible for where are there words
that help us see what's intimacy look like?
You'll find three Hebrew words in the Old Testament
that start to shed light on that.
One is yaah, which means to know deeply.
Another is sowed,
which means to reveal or to disclose.
So this means deep knowing.
This means to reveal.
And the third Hebrew word that's translated intimacy is
s and it means caring involvement.
So if I am seeking to build
more relational intimacy in my marriage,
then what we want to see is
that there is an increasing amount
or frequency where we share vulnerably
and we give mutually give
to the need, whatever the need is.
So it helps if Joyce wants to know me deeply,
even in what happened to you today.
That's got you. So down.
Now, since you all know I'm a marriage counselor,
I can't share details of
what goes on in the counseling office.
Okay? That's an ethical violation.
I can say I just had some tough sessions today.
I can say that. Does that make sense?
And then that's me revealing
and her caring might sound like
what she just said when Jason shared earlier.
I'm so sorry that that was hard for you today.
I want you to know, not care that transaction takes 60
seconds or less, but it's heart to heart.
Here's what I'm thinking
and feeling that might be tied to an event
or something I'm concerned about.
And here's a word of care.
Instead of her saying, Aren't you
like 70 years old?
I mean, can't you handle stuff like that better?
Are you that weak? I mean, see, that would be like,
I ain't sharing there, I'm not gonna share with her again.
Right? Because that's not safe
to have any message that says your feelings don't matter,
or you should be over that by now.
So we want to practice being appropriately
and relationally intimate with one another.
And we're going to talk about some things to avoid doing
and some things to do as we move through this course. Can
I add something? Sure.
Um,
The caring involvement
to me means once you tell me something really special
and really deep, I I put kid gloves on.
I'm careful about how I bring that up with you. I even do.
Or what it means to you,
because sometimes people get hurt more
when the caring involvement doesn't take
that into consideration.
So Joyce is bringing up an example of being sensitive
and caring about even how we might bring something up or,
but she's not talking about walking on eggshells.
That's different. This is consideration
that she's referring to.
We want to even get to the point
where in our relationships we can talk about things
that are difficult
or really hurtful that need to get better.
But we would say a good guideline to use there when you try
to have such conversations is captured in this verse.
Ephesians four 15, it says, speak the truth in love.
Two ways to violate that verse.
One would be, instead of speaking the truth in love, I I
hurled the truth at you.
I just unloaded on you in an, uh, trying
to make sure you, you heard me,
but not in a good way. Not in love,
Bruce. Yes.
Can I, uh, I heard what you said
and I agree with what you say.
Mm-Hmm. And one, what I find is
I do this like 2, 3, 4, 5 times.
Yeah. By the time I get to my sixth time, it's like,
this is the reality check.
Yeah. How many times do I have to, and then I have,
and I say, the reason I'm doing this today is because
after the sixth time of doing it that way,
and you're not hearing me.
Yeah. I feel like this is the only way
I actually get your attention.
Good point. Can you speak to that please? Yeah.
I'm glad I'm gonna be kind of brief,
but I'll, I hopefully we'll speak to it, um, when,
regardless of who we're trying to talk to, where
that's the dynamic, okay.
It could be a child Mm-Hmm. An adult child or even a child.
But we would say that speaking truth
and love is still a principle to follow.
But wisdom may tell me that in spite of the fact
that I am following scripture in how I speak to things, uh,
I cannot make that other person respond
in the way I want them to.
Okay. So I may be being appropriate,
being biblical, being led
by the spirit in speaking truth and love.
And if that's not being responded to
in a loving way, um, or at all
or any you mean like there, there might be no response.
No response. Okay. No response. It's like it, yeah.
Now that's, I'm glad you brought up.
It's not always, uh, rude response, right? Right.
But sometimes it's no response at all. No response. Okay.
So I'm not trying to drum up any business for me.
That too would be unethical. Okay?
But, but, um, we would say,
obviously that part of the dynamic hasn't changed
and we need to understand
what is going on in the other person.
And it could be they do not have self-awareness
to know why they aren't responding.
Um, they may have no equipping
themselves for that kind of thing in their growing up years.
Um, and I would say when you've tried as hard as it sounds,
you might have tried, then I would say seek help.
But there's all kinds of different help,
not just counselors out there,
but I'd say even this kind of class,
a starting point for many people.
Okay. Side note.
And I, uh, I am watching my clock back there.
I love where they have it placed. It's very visible.
Side note is, uh, the ministry that we were part of, David,
David and Therea started, uh, 35 years ago, started off
with them teaching these courses very much like
what we're presenting right now to ministry.
Couples pastors
primarily and their spouses
with a few Christian counselors thrown in and so forth.
But they would teach them these principles
and do it free of charge.
'cause they didn't want anything
to hinder them from hearing the message.
They would also put them up in a nice
hotel and pay for all of that.
And some of these pastors were not in
big churches like this one.
They were in little tiny churches
where they barely made enough money.
They had to be bi-vocational.
The point there was, they were called to equip the church
for the work of this ministry.
And if your pastor's marriages aren't solid,
I didn't say perfect, but if they're not solid and grounded
and healthy, the church may not
be it.
It definitely has an impact.
So that's how they started doing this, was teaching it
to the leadership
and then giving them resources if they wanted
to teach it themselves beyond it.
So anyway, I hope that's a starting point for that.
Thank you for sharing that.
Um, so given these three words
and their meanings, deep knowing, uh,
not only, uh,
the revealing say if I'm talking about Joyce in me, it says,
both of us hopefully want
to know the other person's heart deeply.
And hopefully both of us are learning how to reveal
what we feel, what we think and what we hope for.
And then hopefully both of us respond
with caring involvement.
Now, if we are on the same page
and we're just learning that, that's great,
we'll probably make some good progress.
But one thing that is helpful is to
do a check in with your own heart.
How much equipping did I get
experientially growing up?
I'm not talking about did your parents teach you a class?
I'm talking about experiences in which
you experienced someone deeply knowing you
and creating a safe place for you to reveal
what you're thinking, what you're feeling
and carrying involvement.
That if you shared that you were scared
or that you were hurting, you would receive what you needed,
such as comfort, safety, someone standing up for you.
Who knew you liked that growing up?
Some of you may have heard this illustration,
but my dad was the one that hugged us
and was a soft-spoken, kind, loyal,
easy guy to love.
And he meant the world to us kids.
And he, and he expressed his affection perfectly to all
of us on a regular basis.
We knew we were loved by him experientially.
In addition, he would take us to games and stuff like that.
My mom was also a very devoted mom.
She just had a much more stern and harsh dement.
And she was determined that she was going to raise us
to be successful.
And we didn't understand growing up why
that was so important to her.
We figured that out later on.
But we didn't have the same warm fuzzies with her.
So I was gonna say, oh, my dad
is the one who knew me like that.
But here's a problem with that.
I, I'd have had to lie or be in denial.
It wasn't that he didn't love me as much as he could, is
that we never had the deep conversations.
And I just don't think he was equipped to do that.
I don't think he received that.
I don't think he knew how to do that.
Plus he worked six days a week real hard.
But it was basically, I just don't think he ever had any
help dealing with his emotions.
And I've got lots of examples that I witnessed of him
as I got older where I could see he doesn't know
what in the world to do with his own pain.
He just stuffs it. I I wasn't gonna say my mom
because of her disciplinary role that she didn't come to me.
But I did have a, a grandma who lived in the same hometown
and would often take myself
and my ki my siblings, uh, on excursions, picnics,
hiking trips, stuff like that around our town.
And I remember her crawling in a cave with me one time
that we found in Osage County of all places,
which is the subject of a movie
that you might have heard of.
She crawled into that little cave with me.
And I can, I have a faint memory of her talking about,
we're the outlaws and your brother and sister are the posse
and they don't have the foggiest idea of where we are.
And I'm like, damn.
Now what did that make you feel when I told you
that story included?
Included. Included.
Okay, anybody else when I just made
that story or shared that story?
Just kind of energized. Energized. Okay.
Happy, happy for you. Yeah.
Don't miss that. Connected. Sorry. Connected. Connected.
Yeah. I just shared that in very briefly.
It had an impact on many of you.
It was actually an impact
that in most cases was probably for me.
Though, you might have been also thinking of experiences
of your own, that would be normal.
But what you just did when you said happy, connected, some
of these other words energized.
What you just did was Romans 1215 a
rejoice with those who rejoice.
See, I told you a story about my
grandmother who's long gone.
But it was a very good connection for me growing up.
She was Grandma Sue.
She was a hoot, but she connected with me.
And when I shared that you, some of you, most
of you possibly felt a measure of joy, we're saying
that's Romans 1215.
And guess what? That's a command in scripture.
It's a good God saying, Hey,
if you guys will just connect more,
life will be a little better.
In the same verse it says, mourn with those who mourn
or weep with those who weep.
Mm-Hmm. In this one short verse,
we have two extremes of connection
and we're commanded to go there in both of them.
So when Joyce and I are learning to know each other,
it doesn't have to always be the negative things in life.
It can be the rejoicing things in life.
You know what my opinion is?
Most churches don't do nearly enough rejoicing
with those who rejoice.
I'm not talking about worship time,
I'm talking about personal rejoicing.
Somebody said, man, I, I finally passed
that calculus three class.
I wish I could say that I finally passed that class.
And if someone says, well, you're supposed to, aren't you?
That's on your degree plan, isn't it?
Do you hear any rejoicing in that? No.
That's a flat response.
But if I said, man, I tried three times, never could pass
that class way to go.
That's connection. Okay.
Some of us do it kind of soft spoken.
Some of us are much more vocal.
Doesn't matter what your personality is, you can rejoice
and you can mourn with people.
That's a big deal. And if we didn't experience
that growing up, we have to learn it as adults.
Just have to learn, learn it,
and we believe, let's practice.
So what I want you to do right now, uh,
and if you did this in the, um, Friday night,
Saturday workshop, if you were there
and we had you do this kind of exercise,
I would say just think of somebody else
who might have even in a small temporary way connected
with you and share someone who did connect
with you growing up.
Uh, I had a science teacher that, uh,
thought I was a good student,
but he encouraged me to take that to another level.
And I think he, I got affirmation from Mr.
Kofu when I was growing up
and I could have used a whole lot more affirmation,
but he was one who did that.
See? So there's a rejoicing, so take turns
as a couple, uh, sharing.
Who knew you growing up? You two ladies could share.
Um, looking for, is it,
I don't think we have another man by himself.
I was gonna try to pair you up, but, uh, contact Jason.
There you go. You're stuck now.
Okay. Alright. Go ahead and start sharing now.
Take a minute to do this.
Oh, that'd probably be easier. Okay. I
Was gonna help her wrap that.
Thank you. Then.
So we're supposed to talk about some person
that affirmed us or validated us.
Do you have someone ready? Okay. I'll,
it's interesting to me that
that's still something you enjoy doing
and that's part of the reason why you really like knowing,
you know, like being able to name all the people.
Um, I mean, I'll just go with the one that I,
I wrote about, which was my grandma.
Um, I vividly remember, uh, a time where we got to,
um, pay my grandma before he passed away.
And my brother and I, for some reason, I don't know why,
we had to spend like a week at my grandma's house.
And I remember she had a gift
for us every morning we'd open up.
So we'd open up this present
and the present was a hint of what grandpa that day.
And so like one of the days it was like flashlight, that
symbol on the ceiling.
It was like space. And
that day he took us to the Space Museum.
I got my space pen from him.
He talked about the shows, all the plane things
that we knew about the engine and stuff.
And, uh, took us to a restroom and train.
Um, But, uh, I just felt thought one,
that first person I felt like kind
of informed without knowing me at all,
just straight up was your dad when he just right away,
you know, helped me go to work, trusted me
to drive the tractor, and trusted me to learn how to fail.
Um, Afraid and worried
That It wouldn't be like, you know, as big
or as strong or whatever, your brothers or I,
He just, I felt
family and trusted.
Yeah.
We
Got about two more minutes before we need to
Wrap Up this,
This was Grandma Betty.
Okay. If I could give you a chance
to, uh, wrap up
and if you want to return there
or you can stay where you are.
Okay. That that'd be fine.
So, um,
notice what you're feeling right now.
I say that because
that was something I failed to do
for the first 19 years for marriage.
I did not notice what I was feeling.
My job was to do, not to be. Does that make sense?
I was raised with the idea that what matters
and what brings you worth is how much you can do.
Mm-Hmm. And I'd say in our culture,
probably worse than I've seen in my entire life.
We have a problem being with
People So much animosity.
We know that's not coming from God.
So notice what you're feeling,
whether it's positive or sadness.
Uh, sometimes when we think of things that weren't there,
it brings a measure of sadness
and we're saying that's part of the healing condition.
But if you are sad, it would be helpful If someone is sad
for you, someone comforts you.
Someone says, I wish
that hadn't been the way it was 'cause I care about
Um, if you experienced a good
memory, uh, it's good to notice that too
and to actually dwell richly in that.
'cause the word says God rejoices with
You.
Well, I, when I finish today,
and I have a feeling I'm going
to go about five minutes long,
but if I reassure you it won't be more than five minutes,
it might give you some security.
But if you have to go
and I haven't finished, please, I understand.
But I want to finish with not the connection,
the focus on the connection in the marriage,
but a focus on the connection with God.
Could it be that even as I said earlier, that
unless we see people the way God sees them,
we can't love them the way he loves them saying,
we really need to understand more about what's
going on inside of them.
But could it also be true that if we don't see God
as he really is, we can't love him with our entire heart,
mind, soul, and strength.
Great commandment says, love him
with everything you got heart, mind, soul, and strength.
Well, if you don't see him as he really is,
that might be difficult.
Um, I didn't come to faith in Christ
until I was 29,
but I had been in church from the time I was a little boy.
So I, I had learned a lot about God
and most of it was good stuff that I learned about
That somehow I still had this impression
that God was more focused on my bad behavior than anything
else That make sense?
Mm-Hmm. Now he does care about our bad behavior, doesn't he?
Mm-Hmm. That's very, very sound scripturally.
But if that's all that I think he's concerned about,
I'm really missing the mark.
And if that's all I see him caring about,
I've got an inspecting God
that's my primary image of him.
And I would say that is far from
everything that I need to see.
Or what if I have
felt like an outsider most of my life
or growing up at least like one who didn't fit in
and almost everybody was kind of distant to me.
What if I had a parent who didn't talk to me,
didn't, didn't enter my world at all, then I might
project that onto God as well.
Psychologically, intellectually, I might project that.
It's kind of like if you're the father figure in my life
and you don't connect with me, then I might see God
as must be like you.
And that would leave me probably having a sense of,
I've got a distant God,
he's too worried about planning the second coming.
He doesn't have time to deal with me.
Mm-Hmm. Okay. Third example of
a distorted view of God
or a one-sided view of God might be
that he's a condemning God.
That when he looks at me,
all he can do is think, oh, you disappoint me all the time.
I can't believe you don't know how to pray yet
I can't believe that you haven't led anybody to Christ yet.
See, that's a disappointing God.
If you fail inspections with an inspecting God,
you're probably gonna end up
with a disappointed image of God.
Now folks, I'm standing here
before you saying I knew my Bible.
I even went to seminary for about three years.
I should know the right answers to is God a loving God?
Yes, he is. He's a welcoming God. He's an accepting God.
He's a gracious God.
He longs to show me grace.
So don't you think for a minute about
have I tended to see God in one of those distorted ways?
I'm not saying you don't know the truth.
I'm saying that might be who shows up in your gut
When You've messed up.
We've got a God who gives us do overs
and has already assured us,
even if we don't get the do over right,
he's got a place to reserve for us.
And he's having,
he longs to show us grace.
According to Isaiah eight, uh, 30 18,
David Ferguson that you saw earlier who was our boss
and mentor, still told a story
of his first grandchild.
A little boy named Zachary.
And Zachary lived three doors down from us when
we were in Austin, Texas.
His parents, Zach and Robin, I
and Robin, I'm sorry, his parents were really good parents
and Robin worked at the ministry
and we knew Ike really well.
Got along well. Ike's an OU fan that made it better.
So when little Zachary was about a year old, Dave
and Theresa would sometimes go over
and house, sit for 'em while they went on a weekend, uh, bed
and breakfast getaway.
David said they were doing that one weekend.
And on that Saturday he woke up
and he was just having a cup of coffee
and having a little quiet time in the living room.
And Theresa came in
and sat down, started looking at a magazine.
And so he just kept having his quiet time.
And then they hear little Zachary stirring in the bedroom
because they had one of these remote, um,
audio things where you could hear 'em.
They hear him stirring and Theresa jumps up out of her sofa
and goes running in there to spend some time with Zachary.
Why do you think she's doing that?
Come on. Why is she running in to see that little baby
Cynthia woke Up, that's her grand baby.
She can't wait to see him, right? Mm-Hmm.
She wants to spend time playing with him, right?
Holding him, looking in his eyes, talking
to him like the mom in the still face video.
And David said as she did that,
he got an impression from the Lord that said, David, that's
how I feel towards you when you wake up in the morning.
Mm-Hmm. I'm excited to love you.
I can't wait to spend time with you even though you mess up.
You're My boy. He said, I,
he had been a Christian for 30 some years by the end,
been in ministry most of that time.
And he said, I've never had that thought come across.
He said, I probably had, he said,
I he had an inspecting God, which might have had something
to do with his father being a marine drill
instructor and an alcoholic.
Not a good combination. Theresa had a distant God.
She had a family of six kids
and three of them were profoundly deaf
and both parents worked minimum wage jobs.
There was no time for Theresa.
I had the disappointed, God,
I failed inspection way too many times.
Who did you have? But I let you share that later
since now we're, we'd be outta time.
I want to close with a video of David speaking to this issue
Of A God who is
excited to show you Grace.
I was about, uh, mid midway through the year in, uh,
the book of Isaiah and I came to the passage in Isaiah.
I remember one particular year, I was about midway
through the year in, uh, the book of Isaiah
and I came to the passage in Isaiah 30, verse 18.
And, uh, it really startled me that morning as the,
as the passage says, the Lord longs to show you grace,
and he rises to give you compassion.
I know that that word longs really has an idea
of God is excited, almost kind of ringing his hands,
uh, to give us grace.
And I remember the impression that morning, David is, uh,
that's oftentimes not the way you see me.
Uh, you see me more as a God of
what we might call reluctant grace.
Uh, you know, it's like my concept sadly at times was, God,
he's gonna gimme grace, but he's not really happy about it.
You know, he, he's gonna forgive me.
Um, but it's all,
after all, you know, it's almost like he's God.
He has to. And the impression was very clearly,
no, David, I'm excited.
I I'm wanting to give you grace. I'm wanting to forgive you.
'cause in this call to love like Jesus,
it really is the idea that only to the extent that we're,
uh, experiencing the deepened intimacy of his love,
can we pass that love along to other people.
And so I remember the more I thought about
that was if I have a God who's kind of reluctant, uh,
to give grace or reluctant to forgive,
that can come out in my relationship
with my wife or with my children.
And what's helped me is
to meditate on that from time to time.
And I thought it might be important maybe today for us
to just pause and meditate on
that particular passage of scripture.
Take some time now to continue your Jesus story.
First, listen to his voice and hear what he wants to,
Sorry,
Just for you.
And after you've heard from him,
respond back to him in a personal way.
Tell Jesus what's on your part.
You'll have about 15
or 30 seconds right now to just reflect on that.
Lord, we thank you that we can pause now
and we can imagine that the great high priest Jesus
of sitting in the right hand of the Father, um, is wanting
to minister us grace and compassion.
Would you just picture and imagine in your heart
and mind right now, however you imagine Christ,
however you picture him.
And as you enter his presence, as you approach the throne
of grace, imagine that, that Christ
is excited to embrace you.
He's excited to love you. He's excited to welcome you.
He's excited to give you grace.
And even at your points of disappointment or sadness
or sorrow or pain, imagine now that Christ rises,
he rises to hurt with you.
He rises to give you compassion.
He is the God of all comfort.
And you sense from him the tenderness
and the care of his heart for the pains of life,
the sorrows of life.
And he experiences
and expresses that compassion as a great high priest
who can sympathize for he himself and his humanity.
Experience the disappointments, a man acquainted
with sorrows and grief.
Would you allow the Holy Spirit to just impress you
with an embracing grace filled, compassionate Jesus?
And now, would you allow your heart to give him thanks?
And out of the gratefulness of that kind of love,
freely having received of your grace freely having received
of your compassion, would you empower us
to freely give it this coming week to those nearest us,
beginning with a spouse who blessed us with in Jesus' name?
Amen.
Let me just, uh, close this by, uh, the word of
I remember one particular year, I was about mid midway
through the year in, uh,
I think I'm having a panic, uh, panic factor.
Um, I just encourage you that we're all works in progress.
We're building on whatever is already good in there,
but the Christ in you wants to love this one next to you
even more, and you're his vessel, just like I am for Joyce.
Father, be with us this week as we go. In Jesus' name, amen.
Amen. Thank y'all for giving me five extra minutes.
Absolutely appreciate you so we'll.